being in the IT industry for 20 plus
years has taught me one thing you need
to keep updating your skills on a
regular basis no matter what level
you're at I recently completed the
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning from Simply learn
in partnership with Purdue University
and I must say it was very insightful I
wanted to have a better understanding of
AI and ml to effectively manage a design
and development of the products of the
company and this course has helped me do
exactly that hi I am Hussein Ari Mirza I
live in San Jose California I moved to
the US around 20 years back throughout
my career I have worked at large
organizations as well as startups right
now I work as vice president a product
and customer operations albino Digital
Services and AI based startup in Silicon
Valley I split my time in between two
products one is AI based chatbot which
is for focused at auto dealerships the
second is a video compression Technology
based on AI and ml as a senior
professional this course has helped me
to more effectively manage Ai and ml
projects in my current organization I
have also gained a better Hands-On
knowledge with a better understanding of
the Practical possibilities this helps
me work more efficiently with my team
while we are planning and implementing
our products and services overall I had
a wonderful experience with simply learn
the course material was comprehensive
and the faculty was extremely
experienced The Faculty was able to
adjust their teaching style in order to
cater to the overall skill set of the
class industry relevant projects are
based on real life scenarios this helps
in reinforcing a practical aspects of AI
ML and helps to correlate it with real
life projects which I work with on an
everyday basis when I I'm not working I
love to travel and explain aliens
Outdoors especially hiking I also enjoy
the music movies hanging out with
friends I feel downtime when you are not
working is very important in order to
make your work life a lot more effective
in the rapidly evolving world of
technology it's important to keep up
Skilling for every working professional
stay relevant continue learning